good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Thursday welcome to the
back ladder half of the week
congratulations girlies we did it hey
Jax hey it Aaron I'm darn great thank
you for asking so joy that it's Thursday
such as simcha and I was gonna say that
everyone is celebrating accordingly as
we gear up for the end of the week
it's almost here you guys not only is it
the end of the week but next week is
Thanksgiving so most people should have
a nice short week next week where really
officially have entered holiday season I
mean we know holiday season is being
kicked off when toastmerch.com is lit up
with the new holiday merch collection
from the toast girlies oh yeah and we
kicked off holiday season early because
we want to make sure everyone gets their
holiday gifts in time for the holidays
now speaking of holiday gifts I had a
transformative evening because I saw all
of my holiday shopping done someone I
need to thank this person sent me
Patricia altshul's Instagram where she
did a post about how you can order from
Buckingham Palace gift shop online and
they send it to you in the mail and it's
like premium premium stuff how much was
shipping uh there wasn't like a crazy
shipping cost they ship internationally
DHL so also like if it's good like I
know a gift shop could be like a little
yikes but if it's good enough for
Patricia it's good enough for you yeah
no I wouldn't assume Buckingham Palace
gift shop to be like you know a Hudson
News gift shop you just you never know
what kind of quality they're putting
into their gift shop I was on the
website four hours last night like
they have the most amazing gifts for
everyone in your family but also just
things for yourself things that you need
like I got an apron which I've been
feeling like I need my 2023 planner
that's Buckingham Palestine like it's so
Queeny I would have gotten something for
you but I just didn't feel like you
would want that so why because you're
just really like anti-royal really uh
that's how is that the case
how's that the case don't be revisionist
history because you're bitter because
you took it a little too far uh I am an
enormous fan of the family I watch a
crown in two days I'm just trying to
reel you in a little bit for the sake of
the business not for any other reason
sure well they have amazing things
amazing things for kids like it was the
highlight of my day and I just wanted to
share that pass it along like things you
could never dream of they have no that's
a nice it's hard to find unique new
gifts feels like everyone's getting the
same thing that's why you gotta shop our
toast sponsors for your stocking
stuffers and Shop Buckingham palace.com
right and our toast approved holiday
gift guide we do a holiday gift guide
every year on the patreon you know we
should do that for November like this
month because we don't want to wait too
long yeah people love our gift cards and
like Amazon gift guide just like
everything that we think would make
great gifts
I'm like not a good Gift Giver also like
there's so many things that like stink
about being Jewish during this time of
year like you just are so left out but
whatever everyone's like I got to do my
holiday shopping like you don't really
have holiday shopping like Hanukkah
gifts when you're a kid or a thing you
get like a toy
um but like as an adult it's like not
really a thing so when everyone's like
running around the mall last minute
trying to get you know do my Christmas
shopping like we don't have to do that
so that is kind of nice no but I'm
feeling like this year I just want to
get people gifts for the holidays who
knows when they'll come when you'll
receive them there's no Rhyme or Reason
it's just I'm feeling festive and
generous well you have my address so
feel free I'm always thinking of you and
I'm oh anytime I see a Claudia actually
I did see a gift no I shouldn't have got
it for you because I've gotten you one
before and you didn't even like it but
it was a puzzle a queen puzzle on the
website
you know I actually probably would have
liked that but I just got to a place in
my life where I was talking about like
how much I loved puzzles and then
literally I got like 18 puzzles from
different people and I was like all
right first of all I don't like puzzles
that much second of all I'm very
specific when it comes to puzzles like
if you're gonna give me a landscape like
a green garden and the whole thing is
green like I'm not doing it I need an
easy-ish puzzle like you know what I
mean you know what else I got like so
[ __ ] cute they have a lot of kids
pajamas and they have uh footed onesie
baby pajamas that are uh Buckingham
Palace guards costume deceased deceased
I got some books they have some nice
history books I got a royal line of
succession because I just need a family
tree that I can always reference or not
reference
or you know throw it up put it in a
blender exactly
um well it is Thursday so if I have this
like pep in my step today that's why
okay no it's so good to know it's
important to always reference like why
you're in a good or bad mood you know
what I mean totally and they have sweets
biscuits so much good food stuff you can
get a hamper I didn't know that's what
it's called and it's like all these food
gifts you can get something to throw
your dirty undies in well and then I
guess you could use it as a hamper the
Queen's hamper
undies at auction yeah
um so it's Thursday which means we have
an amazing show because Spirits are high
here at the toast because it's Thursday
and clearly somebody got their holiday
shopping done early and she's on cloud
nine so it means fabulousness Forever on
fabulous news fabulous stories fabulous
sponsors Fabulous Girls lots of fabulous
City lots of fabulosity and then the
rest of my week it's time you guys we're
one week for the Homemakers out there
we're one week out from Thanksgiving and
so it's time to start prep I didn't
realize if you're cooking your own
Thanksgiving like you don't cook
everything the day of not even close
like you of course not desserts a few
days in advance because those can go
straight in the freezer you do gravy
beforehand like a bunch of other stuff
so on the day of it's as easy as
possible so I need to start like making
my grocery list getting everything I'm
gonna make my gravy and we'll take it
from there but this is my first time
hosting Thanksgiving and I'm not taking
it lightly and it's a huge undertaking I
commend you because when one thing about
me I'm a permanent guest I'm not a host
I'm a guest so for me the prep really
starts about an hour before some
Foundation some concealer some contour
and I'm ready to go yeah plus you want
to set your table whenever you have an
opportunity to because that can be done
yeah that shouldn't be a day of thing
because that can sit out for a month
yeah just don't let it get Dusty
how many people are you having over
just four adults three children one
Bryce
um yes
changes everything yeah
how is my Bryce he's good they also have
some gifts for pets at the Buckingham
gift shop of course
um that's not surprising no by any means
because one thing about the queen is
that she respected the stripes Brothers
Oh indirectly but big time except do you
see that scene in the crown when the
romanovs were about to be murdered and
there was a Cavalier in the mix yeah I
did it was really upsetting just wanted
you to know when all the history that
I've read I never read that the romanovs
had a Cavalier because that's something
I would have remembered so I'm pretty
like I just don't want to get too upset
but there were definitely dogs at a
party of house that's for sure well the
crown is fiction also
but it's like not
but they're therein lies the proof we're
in this in between and and that's the
problem like we don't know what's true
and what's false
no that's kind of like Danielle stab I
feel like the crown is really in their
Danielle's style Bearer like there is no
in between with them no they're only in
between they're The Amity precisely
precisely what I said not at all exactly
it's exactly what I said I know that's
one of your other favorite things to say
it is because sometimes like the only
thing that can really wrap up like
whether we're having a debate or we're
talking sometimes the only way to
perfectly wrap up a conversation is in
think looking at it through the lens of
Danielle stab season one tagline you
either love me or hate me there is no in
between with me it was a chapter title
in one of my books I feel as though it
is one of if not the most important
quote of our lifetime
more important than the law is reason
free from Passion
it's up there if I had to have a list of
like maybe five or ten those two would
definitely both be on there okay
another one would be you either die the
hero or live long enough to become the
villain
that's a very like a bone chilling quote
yeah sometimes and I guess this is where
like Instagram quote culture like comes
into play because sometimes like a quote
can really like
shift perspectives
yeah
yeah it's beautiful
um speaking of Danielle's stab we've got
some big Real Housewives news today some
drama in the New York reboot which we're
gonna discuss and
get into and we have some other stories
I know you threw a royal story in there
it's okay I did oh you know what I
actually didn't make the cut maybe
tomorrow oh maybe tomorrow okay or we
can talk about it now no I need the the
facts and the names and everything um
maybe tomorrow maybe I'll take another
look while you're reading an ad so no no
no it's okay
I shouldn't have brought it up I
shouldn't have brought it up without
further
where is Brew he doesn't come to work
anymore
he's like Mom get off my back
Bruce says the same he says do your own
damn work
sounds like Foo he says get the [ __ ] out
of my house
they say
where's my food go work and put some
food on the table
they hate their mom and Auntie damn
those stripes Brethren they can turn on
a dime it's so true bro so true now
without further Ado here are the fast
five stories that you yes you need to
know
and today's episode is brought to you by
the iconic the award-winning sparkling
cocktail
Spritz Society if you haven't already
heard and you definitely should have
heard Spritz Society was named the best
canned cocktail by USA Today if that
isn't a reason to try these sparkling
cocktails for the first time then we
don't know what is spirit Society takes
all-natural recognizable ingredients
packs them into a convenient sparkling
canned cocktail that you can take
anywhere they're low calorie low sugar
drinks with six percent ABV and five
iconic flavors to choose from grapefruit
blood orange Peach pineapple and lemon
there's a little something to fit every
Vibe so it's like I could share with you
my favorite flavors they're Peach and
grapefruit but Sprint Society is so
personal like everyone has a different
favorite like there is a lemon cult
there's a big pineapple Community I'm a
grapefruit and Peach girly but honestly
like
the longer I get into the night I'll
really take anyone they're so good it's
the perfect thing to drink outside with
family perfect thing to bring to a
dinner party one of the four packs has a
bottle and a half of wine so that's a
lot of wine they're six percent ABV and
now we sell variety packs where you can
get the four iconic flavors all in one
if you don't know what to try first get
the Spritz variety eight pack it
features all four of the original
flavors and then you can add Peach to
your cart and complete the whole set of
course so we always have a code for
spritz Society here at the toast because
we are founders of the brand use code
toast t-o-a-s-t for 10 off at Sprint
society.com that's toast for 10 off at
spritzociety.com
s-p-r-i-t-z society.com
great thank you so much
you're welcome
first story Lizzie savetsky has exited
Real Housewives of New York reboot over
anti-Semitism so page six has reported
that Lizzie savesky has quit the Real
Housewives of NYC the reboot before the
new season has even wrapped multiple
sources told page six the social media
influencer who is Jewish received a wave
of anti-Semitic comments when she was
announced as a cast member as soon as
she was announced she was getting insane
threats and anti-Semitism on social
media a source familiar with the show
told page six another Insider added that
Lizzie was quote scared then Lizzy
posted yesterday on her Instagram saying
I will not be continuing on the Real
Housewives of NYC as a proud Orthodox
Jewish woman I thought participating in
this series would be a great chance to
represent people like me and share my
experience unfortunately from the time
of my announcement in the cast I was on
the receiving end of a torrent of
anti-Semitic attacks as discontinued I
realized that this path was no longer
right for me and my family I'm looking
forward to my next chapter stay tuned
thank you for your love and support
so I feel like there's two things going
on here the first is like I have no
doubt that when she was announced she's
Orthodox Jewish she's very you know uh
proudly pro-israel she was gonna get
absolutely annihilated because being
pro-israel is like these days like the
worst thing you can do when it's
actually quite a lovely thing to be
um so I feel like she was probably
prepared for for a decent amount because
that's she's also she's an influencer
and full-time activist for Judaism for
against anti-Semitism for Israel so I
feel like she definitely deals with like
a way like a huge amount of this on a
daily basis and I'm sure when she was
announced it was a level that she didn't
even think was possible but and there
have been
um like lots of rumors going around
about their beings more there
um so I don't want to Discount the fact
that like this definitely played a
factor she has young kids I don't think
really anyone wants to put their family
through that and I actually do think in
the end she'll be really grateful she
didn't do it because like we see this
happen like garcelle I'm like really
pre-established franchises with
well-respected Housewives who have like
earned their credit
um even they are not above the crazy
Bravo fan attacks so I do think in the
end she'll be happy she didn't do it um
but there is something else going on
because I don't think you know this is
it yeah because from they announced that
she was a cast member officially at
bravocon we've known for months that she
was going to be a cast member I think
she's received a lot of anti-Semitism
even a lot of some of the Bravo fan
accounts have posted the news that she
was leaving I was reading the comments
and it's like that's the kind of
anti-Semitism that you need to worry
about saying that Bravo should have
never cast her because she has the word
Zionist in her bio right all of these
like horrible things that are
it's so it's so messed up and it's not
even like necessarily quote unquote
threatening or violent it's just like
blanketly not accepting her because
she's a Zionist and that's the worst
thing dismissing her existence entirely
so I think that when she joined and she
got this Tarn of anti-Semitism which
she's so online and she's so pro-israel
and that's just not they don't know it's
a scary place to be I imagine that at
first she was like no I'm gonna stand
firm in my spot because I'm going to be
on the show and I'm going to show
everyone like what it is to be an
Orthodox Jewish woman what it is to be a
Zionist and what I'm doing is important
and then from what we understand
something happened while they were
filming I've now we heard it like
Through the Grapevine and Page Six also
reported on their Tick Tock that there
was an event and Lizzy is a Matchmaker
Jewish Matchmaker and one of the women
wanted Lizzy to set her up to meet
someone and we did some researchers
there's only three single women on the
show so yes uh Jenna Lions ubah Hassan
and Brynn Whitfield I had heard that it
was Brynn but it could be any of the
three women because they're the only
single one single and so they asked like
Lizzy like oh could you set me up and
Lizzy said that she only sets up Jewish
people with Jewish people and then the
person said something to the effect of
that's what Nazis do and called Lizzy a
Nazi right she said like uh my the point
of my matchmaking is to further the
Jewish population so I actually only set
up Jewish people with other Jewish
people and the girl I think Brynn but
any of those women said um well that
sounds like something anatsu would say
right that's what the Nazis did that's
what she said and which is really
um like not an okay thing to say and
what's so weird to me is like because
this is so Under Wraps it's like
Lizzie's getting dragged right now on
social media
um by like the Bravo fandom when in
reality like
she was literally called a Nazi and I
just want to say like I guess to some
people that saying like I would only set
up Jewish people with Jewish people is
like a crazy thing or offensive but let
me tell you I know a million girls from
high school people I'm still friends
with who run these like matchmaking
groups the whole point is to marry off
like young Jewish men with young Jewish
women
um it's a very common thing like we're
just now getting back to pre-holocaust
numbers like furthering the Jewish
population and
um ensuring the existence of the Jewish
people for generations to come is a very
common thing it's a very okay thing
there's literally nothing wrong with it
I feel like we've said you know multiple
times on the show like personally like
when I was dating like I would only
consider Jewish
candidates and that's a personal
preference and that's a preference of a
lot of people I think it's a preference
of a lot of people in different
religions it's not an exclusively Jewish
thing it's great to do others I Empower
everyone to do whatever they want but
dating you have preferences and everyone
has their own preferences and that's
okay no and Jews are not the only
minority Community who want to stick
together stick together and like there's
a number of reasons why I think for
Lizzy like her mission of being a Jewish
matchmaker is you know the Jewish
population was depleted after the
Holocaust and as you said like we're
just getting back to those numbers and
that's an important mission of hers also
like a lot of Jewish people want to be
with other Jewish people because you
have a lot in common you have similar
values interests taste in food even like
it's just and a lot of minority
communities are in this same thing the
same way so it's not like a crazy crazy
thing no and by the way that's not
something that makes you a Nazi and the
Nazis weren't like Nazis because they
wouldn't marry outside of the Nazis were
Nazis because they were like murderous
genocidal monsters
like her Jewish brothers and sisters to
marry each other really that's a stretch
no and I know like people on the
internet like are constantly jumping to
a conclusion so it's important to also
know like just because you want to marry
someone from your own faith or you want
to set up other people from your own
faith doesn't mean you like hate inter
Faith or interracial marriages that's
literally not the what we're saying like
I think that [ __ ] is fabulous I think
you should matter whoever the [ __ ] you
want I love that for you but personally
like when I was dating I was only
looking at a certain pool of people
people
um so just keep in mind like just
because you say one thing that doesn't
mean like you hate the other you know
just because the internet is like so
[ __ ] crazy sometimes yeah you can two
things can be true yeah you can love all
marriages
right but if you'd like to want to be a
Matchmaker you have your particular area
of focus
like I'd like to feel like a Stanger
does she hate poor people because she's
The Millionaire Matchmaker actually I do
think Patty singer hated poor people
um so I just think this is like a really
interesting thing going on because like
Lizzy is being dragged by the fandom for
being like Jewish and Zionist and and
all these things and it's like where is
the person who called the Jewish girl a
Nazi like where's the Dragon for her
most people don't know the story of what
happened and they're just seeing that
Lizzie left because of anti-Semitism
which is not really
it's not the whole story and and
therefore it's like kind of weird
because she was experiencing
anti-Semitism the whole time so why now
why would you leave now and so I think
people don't have the information but
they're just going off of like well good
she should have never been on her views
are crazy she's a Zionist and it's like
and then it goes back it's like Bravo
needs to start betting their candidates
better and it's like just because a
housewife doesn't agree with everything
you think doesn't mean that they
shouldn't be a housewife vetting their
candidates like she's some kind of
criminal yeah no no like read the
comments on those Bravo no I can't it's
too upsetting it's really too upsetting
like being a Zionist and supporting
Israel the Jewish homeland is literally
the most normal thing ever it's totally
okay if you don't agree with it okay
sure whatever we are all complex human
beings but like [ __ ] off stop making it
out to be this thing where it's like
you'd be thrown in jail it's like it's
not like someone should be like written
off canceled it's a a controversial
unsavory view it's none of those things
it's not it's not and I refuse to accept
that narrative I really do yeah so I
can't read that [ __ ] it really upsets me
like I just can't believe that there's
like one tiny slice of land for the Jews
literally we were murdered we need our
Biblical Homeland I can't people are
dumb ugly stupid and annoying and I hate
you all Claudia they can have that one
tiny slice of land they just can't it's
too much
it's too much it's too much land
it's just one
one country for the Jews Christian
countries there are the size of New
Jersey
it's too much New Jersey they can't have
it
well I have reached out to Lizzie
offering her a platform here on the show
I would love to hear what she has to say
I have met her on at like Jewish events
she's like very involved in the
community and she's a great spokesperson
for the Jewish people and I was really
looking forward to seeing her on the
show also I thought it was really cool
that production was like real they
really wanted her on the show she's very
she's much more religious than we are so
that means like there's a lot more
restrictions for her for Shabbat she
can't travel she can't use Electronics
all the holidays like we're you know
less religious than that so I loved that
production was going to make all these
you know things work for her
logistically I thought it was really
cool like a you know New York is the
biggest most dense population of Jews in
America I thought it was great that we
had a girly on there
um
and I just think this reboot is not off
to a great start no and I have a few
questions now because it's like I don't
know how much footage they have are they
going to take Lizzy out of everything I
don't know are they going to show what
happened and then how Lizzy walked away
also the page six thing said that this
comment from the cast member happened
and then I think Productions response to
it is what was the final nail for Lizzie
and left like oh like they didn't have
her back yeah something to that effect
like it wasn't just because someone said
something it was the way it was handled
okay well that makes sense too because
it's a crazy ass thing to say yeah also
like lest we not forget Lizzy was
supposed to be on Real Housewives of
Dallas and then they never got there
last season then she was moving to New
York and they put her on Legacy but she
was the first cast member that was
rumored to be announced and I can't
believe that she's not doing it no
because it seems like they like really
wanted her in the franchise in one way
or the other it seems like like she's
was down like extremely down to be on
reality TV to put herself out there so
like how bad were things that she's not
doing it and she's not even waiting till
the end of the season to see how things
go like goodbye yeah no that's so true
and I am really curious if this is going
to be like completely written out or
it's now like a a big story line I can
imagine I think it'll be in the show
I'd love to see what this comment was
that clearly set her off
yeah
and maybe it was like following a bunch
of other stuff that she experienced on
the show and like you never know what's
gonna be the thing that's like okay yeah
yeah you never know what's the thing
that's going to set you off you know
what Taylor has a really good quote in
one of her songs I think it's dear
reader which is like a little cringy but
um
bet Bend when you can snap when you have
to
yes if that ain't me
if that ain't you
literally not you quoting Taylor oh add
it to the quotes list
update to everyone from yesterday
um for the Capital One pre-sale I was in
the queue for three hours
no tickets remaining I'm with the
General on sale public whatever that is
I've just resigned myself to the sheer
fact that I will be a victim of the
resale market and that's okay it's okay
I'm gonna pay a premium but I'm happy to
do it for my girly now let me ask you
something how is any of that different
from what you said yesterday when we
decided that you were gonna just
well yesterday I still had the hopes of
yesterday but today it was a two-day
pre-sale it was the verified fan
pre-sale which me and Margo got and then
it was Capital One card holder pre-sale
um I did get two of my friends to offer
me their credit cards and I would pay
them back and I didn't even get a chance
to use them because so many people were
in the queue wow
yeah it was very sad
I'm sorry I'm laughing because someone
like sent me a DM saying like tell
Claudia and Margot that they can see
what number they are in the queue if
they go to like the if you right click
on Safari the HTML view page Source
you'll see the back end HTML of the
website and if you go down to line 222
it'll say exactly how many people are in
front of you so I send that to Claudia
and Margo like oh my God I saw the CM
you guys probably like aren't looking at
your DMs right now and then Claudia
wrote back yes we are 28 000 and 22 000
respectfully respect respectively
um yeah I was 22 000 for two hours like
no not a single person moved in front of
me for two hours
and then quickly it dropped to like 14
000 and then I was just it was I knew
when it started dropping really quick
I'm like oh great people are getting in
seeing that it's sold out and leaving
that's why let me ask you something are
you looking to hear from Taylor about
this debacle so there's like a lot of
rhetoric and dialogue people are um
really angry and being like can't
believe Taylor's just left us out here
not saying anything I don't really know
what she could say like Taylor people
are bad at a few things one that the
pre-sale was such a [ __ ] a mess really
there's only so much she could do she
she got her verified pre-sale for fans
she got them to do that first before
Capital One I think she advocated to
Ticketmaster as much as she could I
don't know at some point it is out of
her hands but what people are really
upset about her is for um opting into
Dynamic pricing yes this is what I saw
so what that means is like Ticketmaster
has an option when you're uh an artist
to have Dynamic pricing or not Dynamic
pricing and what dynamic pricing means
is like if a lot of people are buying
tickets all at once you know supply and
demand the the cost will go up because
there's so much demand
um
or you can opt in to have the tickets
stay the same price the whole time no
matter what first come first serve
everyone gets the same pricing Taylor
you know our capitalist Queen
um she opted in for dynamic pricing and
you know you could be mad all you want
but like you would do it too for a check
so sorry Taylor Swift is human alert the
Press I mean I think it was worth
mentioning that Luke Combs has
non-dynamic pricing no of course because
Luke Combs like is the everybody man you
know yeah
I know but and also a lot of parents
were saying no a lot of people were also
comparing to the Olivia Rodrigo sour
tour she had similar like rates of
people showing up and not getting
tickets again she was playing tiny
venues but
um her team there were so many Bots who
then bought tickets and put it on resale
markets her team bought back from from
the Bots from the
ticket resell websites bought them back
and relisted them for like the normal
price on Ticketmaster so the Bots got
their money
yes but then the fans got their tickets
for a normal price nice but I don't like
the Box just getting there I just don't
think like it should be this hard like
why can't a bunch of celebrities like
who have been like Luke Combs and Taylor
like they need to get together they have
enough money between the two of them and
start like a competitor to Ticketmaster
that prioritizes fans that works really
well with artists and between Taylor and
Luke Combs they have so many friends in
the industry they could get like a major
amount of artists to leave Ticketmaster
but the problem is is that and this is
why what everyone's talking about is
that Ticketmaster is a monopoly because
Ticketmaster owns Live Nation and Live
Nation is the biggest promoter of
concert so if you're gonna be out here
doing concerts there's Live Nation AEG
and Outback but Live Nation and AG are
two of the biggest ones you want one of
those to be your promoter you're like
you can't really go on tour without them
they do all the work for you so if you
want Live Nation which is the best
promoter in the country to promote your
concert you then also have to work with
Ticketmaster so that's why a lot of
people are you know complaining that
that never that merger should have never
happened because it is a monopoly
yes but even if Taylor and Luke made
their own ticket platform and
prioritized fans how could they actually
make sure that fans got the tickets it
sounds like she's trying to prioritize
her fans through Ticketmaster yeah how
do you like what could they do
differently really
well I think um a lot of people were
upset that Taylor was allowing uh
six tickets to be bought at a time
because that's what Bots do they buy six
and like set sell you know two sets of
three no three sets of two excuse me
um like that was one thing two also like
for this verified pre-fan sale whatever
you got a code
then you when it was time you would
click the link and you would wait on the
queue for hours and then put in your
code so there was like thousands and
thousands of people who were waiting in
the queue who didn't even have a code
like morons so like why not put the code
in in order to get in line for the queue
you know yeah
so just like logistical things
especially Capital One yesterday you
just basically had to check out with a
Capital One credit card and if you
didn't have a Capital One credit card
your purchase would be declined but it's
like so how come we all could get in
line even if you didn't have a Capital
One credit card and like slow down the
process and crash the website moronic
um
so there were like logistically things
that could have been done better at the
end of the day there isn't a million
things that like Taylor could have done
to prioritize fans like this is how
ticketing Works
um and I think the people complaining
and crying on social media that they
have survivors guilt the ones who got
tickets people really are not okay
they're not saying that seriously they
are they are saying it's dead seriously
I saw a tick tock and I actually made it
they have survivors guilt because they
got tickets and they feel guilty for
those that are out in the cold I I made
a response video and immediately deleted
it because I knew people were gonna call
me out being like it's easy for you to
say like you can afford StubHub and
they're not wrong so like I'm not the
injured party here I think the injured
party are people who really really want
to see Taylor and couldn't get face
value tickets so I I know I think that
people who won't get to go to a concert
that they wanted to go to I would
categorize them as injured too no so it
was this girl like laying in her bed she
had like text all over the screen and
there was just like music playing in the
background she's like I'm feeling so
confused I know millions of people are
hurting right now it was so serious and
like I just had to hop on there and be
like Kim there's people that are dying
like there are Wars going on there are
people with terminal illnesses like you
need to calm down it's a [ __ ]
concert [ __ ] and it's important to
remember this isn't the end like resale
tickets yes are more expensive but like
day of tickets like there are all these
apps you can get like 20 seats like
there's a million ways to go to a
concert if you want to go especially one
at a stadium that seats 80 000 people
calm the [ __ ] down [ __ ] that's so crazy
you need to calm down and I think Taylor
like sang something would kind of
validate people being nuts so I kind of
am here for her silence okay
I don't have a thought on it there's a
lot of toxicity in an entitlement in the
Swift fandom I believe and I think like
Taylor making a statement would then
like embolden enable enable that
entitlement okay unless she was just
like stay patient we're doing our best
thanks for the support
she doesn't have to like apologize or
anything but just be like
shit's crazy thanks for showing up
yeah no she know what she should make a
statement that says yes I am that [ __ ]
like breaking websites breaking credit
card companies
and that's what you get when you're the
biggest star in the world like I I never
heard Coldplay have this problem you
know totally
okay let's turn the whole play into this
two not to drag Coldplay let's move on
to our next story which is Pete Davidson
and emrata have their first picks
together and they're getting cozy so
Pete and Emily are already looking like
a picture perfect couple in matching
outfits uh just days after sources
reveal the two are dating and photos
obtained by Page Six the pair matched in
Black puffer jackets while and white
t-shirts and gray sweatpants while
meeting to celebrate Pete's 29th
birthday they were first spotted
together uh a few days ago P arrived at
Emily's apartment in the West Village
she was walking out to meet his car but
there was too many Paparazzi so she
turned around but last night she walked
into a building and cameras caught them
embracing it was a hug forlorn building
yeah I'm like these are two of the
biggest stars like what is this dump
yeah biggest stars and they're just like
wearing sweatpants and it could just be
like anyone in the world and it looks
like you know like a post-grad walk-up
apartment that has roaches you know yeah
and that's his birthday a celebration
question mark That's Pete the man of the
people yeah I just want to say I'm not
going to be like a really like a denier
a Davidson Rada denier because I don't
care but I thought that that hug looked
like really friendly like I mean by the
way it's important to keep in mind this
is like their second or third date
that's true I guess that's how I would
hug someone that's how you would Embrace
someone who like you're into but like
you're not dating yeah
I thought the same thing too but then
I'm like wait this is blown up so much
but like they were spotted on like four
days ago but you don't think that they
saw each other privately a little bit
before people were showing up at other
people's Apartments maybe maybe but if
that's the case that's still a
relatively new relationship yeah
I thought the Embrace was very like
fratty like I thought he was gonna give
her like a noogie yeah no it's like
she's coming over to his fat house like
here to play Xbox and I'll show you my
room yeah yeah yeah and like we'll play
Xbox with the boys yeah no it was
definitely it was definitely giving like
college embrace
yeah but again maybe that's the Pete
Davidson way I think that they are well
suited and me too age-appropriate
all good all good all good just I love
our first photo it's always a big
milestone in a celebrity relationship it
is it's the one you think of forever
them at Knott's Berry Farm you know
um
are you ready for our next story which
is a little more romance news yes but
literally ever since you brought up dear
reader like in my head I'm like do you
read curling upon I thought you should
know it I kind of like hate that song
I kind of don't like the melody but I
think it might be one of the best
written songs on the album like it's
extremely profound yeah I mean that one
line let's look at the lyrics
yeah dear reader lyrics
dear reader lyrics Dear reader if it
feels like a tricks you're already in
one sure that dear reader get out your
map pick somewhere and just run
okay
dear reader burn all the files desert
all your past lives and if you don't
recognize yourself that means you did it
right
chilling never take advice from someone
who's falling apart ain't that the truth
dear reader Bend when you can snap when
you have to
be a reader you don't have to answer
just because they asked you trills
dear reader the greatest of luxuries is
your secrets
yeah I just agree ever ever had a Birkin
ever had a nice bath a massage
a trip to an island dear reader when you
aim at the Devil make sure you don't
miss agreed agreed so I wander through
these nights I prefer hiding in plain
sight my fourth drink in my hand these
desperate prayer prayers of a cursed man
over my head yeah me too spilling out to
you for free but darling darling please
you wouldn't take my word for it if you
knew who was talking if you knew where I
was walking to a house not a home all
alone because nobody's there where I
Pace in my pen and my friends found
friends who care no one sees you when no
one sees when you lose when you're
playing solitaire
okay actually I wanted to ask you I
needed a clarification on
a Taylor lyric that I feel like nobody's
kind of looked into it's from Karma okay
um should I pull it up no it's just one
line okay put figures down
Karma takes all my friends to the summit
is there something after that
no
well thank you so this what's the summit
the Summit is like the edge of a cliff I
think oh it's not like one of those um
I thought it was one of those like Bill
Gates billionaires those are called
Summits too but isn't there one called
The Summit it's like in Idaho when all
the billionaires go it's not called The
Summit
G1 Summit or something uh it's in like
Sun Valley that is a summit where like
there's a meeting of the mines oh okay
so what is the dictionary definition for
Summit it's like a cliff it is hold on
let me just get that Sun Valley Summit
Karma's gonna track you down step by
step I think it's that's just it's a
conference that Sun Valley think the
Summit is the highest point of a hill or
a mountain
it's also a meeting between heads of
government but I think it's the first
one in her thing Karma takes all my
friends okay and I think when you're at
the highest point of a hill or a
mountain like you could either fall off
of it
no no or you're attending tall yes this
Summit is really like a not a choice but
it could go either way sort of no and I
think the way she's leaning into is like
Karma benefits her friends because all
of her friends reach mountain peaks like
they're all doing well oh true or Karma
and like takes your friends to The
Summit in which case like
when
Karma could be like a negative or a
positive thing and when right of course
when it's a negative thing like her
friends might fall if that's what they
deserve as bad friends no I think it's
the previous yeah it's a positive things
her friends are peaking
because they're good friends because
they deserve it yeah I think it's that
I think it was that do you feel like you
have more clarity now I actually do and
no they don't Karma doesn't take all of
her friends to the G10 Summit that's
what I thought I'm like oh my God I feel
like more people should be talking about
this
Karma takes all her friends to Davos
but right literally
it's really funny
are you ready for our next story now a
little more romance news is it the
romance news that's brought to you by
modern fertility
um
knowledge is power and when you know
more you can make better decisions for
your body your health and your future
there aren't many decisions bigger than
having a kid but for many women their
fertility is a big question mark That's
why modern fertility was created an easy
and affordable way to test your
fertility hormones at home with a simple
finger prick mail it in with a prepaid
prepaid label and you'll get your
personalized results within six days
you'll get insight into your hormone
levels like your ovarian reserve which
is basically how many eggs fewer or more
on average than the woman your age or
other important factors that can impact
your fertility the results will go deep
into what every hormone means and you
can also download the results to review
with your doctor for next next steps
traditional hormone testing at a
fertility clinic can cost over six
hundred dollars but for modern fertility
test the same general set of hormones at
a fraction of the price and if you go to
modernfertility.com toast30 you can get
an additional thirty dollars off your
test plus you can get reimbursed for the
rest through your FSA or your HSA right
now model fertility is offering our
listeners that thirty dollars off the
test us when you go to
modernfertility.com toast30 it's a
limited time offer for the thirty
dollars off and that means your test is
going to come out to just a hundred and
forty nine dollars hormone testing at a
fertility clinic can cost more than
three times as that as much as that so
again get 30 off your fertility test
when you go to modernfertility.com
toast30 it is a limited time offer at
modernfertility.com
t-o-a-s-t number three number zero
modernfertility.com toast three zero
thank you so much mclared
you're welcome I was just thinking about
the summit thing because this book that
I just read said a couple times that
like falling in love is like being on
the edge of a cliff which say falling in
love is like being at the taking it
going to the summit and it's another
thing falling in love can be such a
positive or such a Negative just like
Karma so
oh I learned a new word too I actually
find like that little dictionary feature
on the Kindle to be enormously helpful
because I'm really not like good with
the words
um and there was a word in my book
yesterday that was like so obvious I'm
like how do I not know this word
compulsory
what is it it's like like mandatory yeah
that's a good word I didn't know that
yeah I thought it was a good word I'm
gonna try and use it like I'm gonna use
it in a sentence Jackie
hold on so is it a verb like what
it's an adjective
yeah like you describe something as
being mandatory
Jackie
you look so stunning today I didn't know
sickening was a compulsory
koalas compulsory quality of the morning
toast you didn't Okay so I didn't know
that yet but I was just being fictional
for the sentence yeah I would say
delivering the next stories a compulsory
Act of mine is hosted the morning toast
I would say that as well
are you ready for it I feel like Aquila
at the bay we haven't been ready for
this story no because Aquila and the bee
is the best [ __ ] movie of all time
like Laurence Fishburne's best work of
course Keke Palmer you see Kiki Palmer's
hosting SNL this week no I didn't who's
a musical guest
so it'll be like a really good one and I
feel like Kiki Palmer is the perfect
person for SNL and I'm glad because like
well she might not be like the most
famous they're putting Talent first and
that's where she's gonna Thrive and I
feel like this is gonna be a huge
platform for her and she's going to
become a huge Star as she is but like I
feel like she's gonna become an even
bigger star like so many people who
don't know know her are just gonna love
her upon meeting her and just like find
an enormous respect for her Talent she
sings she dances she acts she does
comedy like I hope she does it all yeah
totally it's gonna be good maybe the
next story isn't one worth telling since
we can't no telling I'm ready I'm ready
Brad Pitt has a new Leading Lady Inez de
Ramon they've been together for a few
months she is the ex-wife of Vampire
Diaries diaries star Paul Wellesley they
separated earlier this year yeah so
she's got great taste in men while Brad
Pitt and Ernesto Ramon were just spotted
together for the first time at Bono's
concert in LA over the weekend insiders
say they've been getting to know each
other for quite some time he being 58
and she is 32 she's also a fine jewelry
executive have been dating she's like so
stunning she's like really classically
beautiful not like this Instagram model
thoughtlandia like she has a real face
yeah and like a real nose she's got a
real watch
and she's quite stunning like she's very
striking looking and she has a real job
I love but you know every time since
Angelina like Brad Pitt has been spotted
with a woman like remember that
Professor that Israeli girl
um it's never like a model like he's
always looking I think he he likes a
good brain he does I feel like well at
this point in his life he is
prioritizing conversations and people
and stuff personal things that because
he's Brad Pitt he gets the girls who are
brainy and beautiful he doesn't have to
choose he doesn't have to choose and I'm
really happy for him and like and this
is kind of what I was saying um of
course it's different but like when I
was saying like Pete Davidson like
choosing emrata like it's so obvious you
know she's the hottest woman in the
world and for me like P Brad Pitt like
choosing this Rando beautiful like
classically stunning accomplished
businesswoman like different like not
celebrity not model like that's an
inspired choice for me I just want to
say like this week when I was saying
like this feels uninspired about Pete
Davidson this is an example of an
inspired choice and this is not pitting
women they're all great women I'm just
saying you yeah but I feel like that's
what Brad's been looking for I feel like
we could have said that even when he was
single like he's not
I think he wants someone who's even
though by the way someone who's he was
recently linked to emrata yeah but who
said that never confirmed also she is
another one brainy and beautiful yeah
but I think he's always been looking for
someone who's industry adjacent has
their own thing going on like someone
who can teach him some a thing or two do
you think Paul Wesley from Vampire
Diaries like woke up today he's like oh
my god what the [ __ ] my wife ex-wife is
with Brad Pitt yes but if they're
separated and divorcing they probably
hate each other and he's like no this is
going to add feelings to you
Brad no yeah totally
but like he's an actor I'm sure like
every male actor like looks up to Brad
Pitt and then it's like your ex-wife is
like hanging out yeah
that's like when celebrities date lay
people at least Paul Wellesley is like
you know he'll he'll he'll be fine
um but when celebrity State lay people
and it's like the lay person's Forex ex
who's a fellow layperson is now dating
Lady Gaga right right that's no that's
like inherently the problem with the
bachelor is that like they all become
it's lay people becoming unlay people
but they're former lay partners are
still lay and they want a piece of the
action yeah of course yeah
anyways happy for Brad Pitt and S no I
like that too like she's honestly like
I'm I'm she has a new fan like I think
she's very beautiful and like I like her
yeah we should check out her jewelry
yeah what's it called no it's she's an
executive so it's not her company no but
like she obviously like works for the
company because she feels passionate
about it yeah I feel like she's probably
like an executive like Tiffany or
something if I had to guess oh no I feel
like it's um
yeah you know like uh
Missouri
okay she graduated from the University
of Geneva with a bachelor with the
bachelor's degree in Business
Administration
Geneva is not Genovia
no I okay
how stupid do you think I am I don't
know what were you about to say Geneva's
like Switzerland right yeah yeah so
she's like a really like hoity-toity
like oh wow it gets hoityier according
to her LinkedIn she previously held
roles in the jewelry department at
Christie's and at a luxury Swiss Jeweler
did grossagano
wholesale for an LA based brand Anita Co
jewelry
oh yeah that that sounds like
what I would think aside from the
Christie's piece so she's fancy and
smart and let me tell you those women
who work for Christie's watch out I
never saw a more fabulous bunch one of
my friends she works at Christie's and I
swear to God she's she's actually not
like other girls she's fabulous which
friend Caitlyn do you know her I think
you do
I met her through Margo not ashrae okay
cool she's really like she's something
else and so I think that's I don't know
what they're giving in the lunchroom at
Christie's but it's fabulosity on a
platter the thing is I think this is
like a nature burst nurture thing and I
don't think it's what they're serving at
Christie's I think it's who they're
letting through the door I think Christy
does the vetting and five of those girls
and then I think Brad Pitt goes to
Christy still to Christie's to shop for
some art and some art
and some art
I gotta get a job at Christie's you
think people let me in the door
that would be the true test yeah like
seriously I could do it I mean I talk so
fast oh I got a piece of iron ready 20
000 sold I think there's a difference
between being an Auctioneer and working
at Christie's but oh you're right
because it's it's very like this
twenty thousand those are the three
civilized no I think one of us working
at Christie's I feel like a few of the
books that I've read have main
characters who work at Christie's or
Sotheby's because it's a very
interesting job and it's a lot of that
actually it's a lot of knowledge about
things like our history jewelry fashion
whatever the category you're in is and
then you like talk to clients and like
explain why something is worth the value
that it has
yeah no you're right I actually also
read a book about a girl who was like
dying to work at Christie's um and she
like conned her way into becoming
friends with one of the Christie's girls
and she like had the knowledge she was
really smart but she was just like a con
woman
um it was a good book yeah I could see a
cotton woman thriving at Christie's
annadelby is perfection
yeah okay ready for our next story
your fave Brendan Frazier will be
skipping the Golden Globes after because
he's scribbled because he's screwed or
scrupled and he had accused Philip Burke
of sexual assault a few years ago he
said in his Sheikh who covers story that
he will not participate in the award
show after the former Hollywood Foreign
Press Association president Philip Burke
sexually assaulted him he said quote I
have more history with the hfpa than I
have respect for the hfpa it's because
of the history that I have with them and
my mother didn't raise a hypocrite you
can call me a lot of things but not that
he had previously claimed in 2018 that
Philip Burke sexually assaulted him
during a luncheon at the Beverly Hills
Hotel in 2003 and caused him to be
blacklisted from Hollywood now even
though Philip Burke is no longer at the
hfpic you would think like okay maybe
Brendan can come in there was no
accountability there was no
accountability they had even done an
investigation when Brendan said what he
said and they said quote although it was
concluded that Mr Burke inappropriately
touched Mr Frazier the evidence supports
that it was intended to be taken as a
joke and not as a sexual Advance
um I don't think it's a joke to put your
finger up someone's butt like you're
kidding right no that's so that's I
think like why the befriend's so deep
it's not it's not about Philip it's not
about the institution the hfpa handled
it and
belittled what he experienced and still
hasn't changed course or even
acknowledged like that's really painful
and I I want to say like I think the
world of Brendan Fraser and this article
like I actually I actually could get
emotional like I think you know
Hollywood is like so
like just full of people who'll do
anything to get ahead and the fact that
like he's had his comeback and he's
still won't he's not gonna like push his
values or his trauma like he is gonna
dig his heels and like at the top of his
game he's still gonna be talking about
the Injustice because it still hasn't
been course corrected and I just love
this man like I have so much respect for
him and I'm so I'm so honored like to be
a part of his comeback I really am so
are you gonna abstain from the Golden
Globes in solidarity with Brendan
I mean I wasn't planning on watching
because like genuinely and I mean this
like in a genuine way like who the [ __ ]
cares
um and also Brennan Fraser is not
attending not interested
um I'll just have to see where I am that
evening but I don't know I I don't think
I need to but would you take a stand
with Brandon sure sure how about this
I'm taking a stand with Brendan Frazier
and I encourage you all to do so let's
boycott the Golden Gloves and I thought
they were kicked off television for like
not having enough money uh and not
having enough interest they're back
okay but also it's it's like okay so
even if it's Sunday night and you are
looking for something to watch you have
to intentionally not watch the Globes to
stand with Brendan yeah I'll read a book
I'll get a snack I'll make a cake
there's a million things I'm a very
interesting person make a chili sure
yum I stand with Brendan Fraser
um I'm assuming he's not gonna win
because he's out here dragging them to
filth which we love but I'm Still
Holding Out for an Oscar for Brendan
yeah who cares about the Globes it's not
even part of the egot it's so true
they're irrelevant nobody's irrelevant
irrelevant uglies yeah
are you ready for our fifth and final
story which is a new trend amongst Mamas
and babies what is it is it upsetting no
it well I mean maybe it's really really
funny The Wall Street Journal just
reported on it but it's been like on
Instagram and Tick Tock for a while and
there's one account that really
harnesses all of the sad beige content
The Wall Street Journal says sad beige
has taken over baby gear clothing and
decor
so
all of the baby gear these days cribs
nurseries if you look at you know inspo
it's all inspo beige and it's like yeah
no baby's favorite color is beige so
true there's this Instagram and Tick
Tock account that's like sad based
children and their sad base toys for sad
base children toys oh that's terrible
kids need color they're all gonna end up
colorblind if they're not exposed to
many colors early on yeah but like you
see these pictures of nurseries and they
really look so gorgeous and so peaceful
right but they're all beige and neutral
but they're all beige and neutral it's
like kids like colors primary colors I
know they're not like aesthetically
pleasing but no but like the wackier the
nursery the happier the baby the more
stimulated I think I was reading a bunch
of quotes from people who think that
like you know if you your baby's in like
a calm beige environment that they might
just be right calm and patients listen
to Mozart happily right but no babies
like our babies as they've always been
throughout time and now and they require
like stimulation it's really like beiges
everywhere market research shows that
beige is picking up Baby Gap has a
designated base section a new line from
Walmart easy peasy includes a lot of
beige too according to Etsy searches for
beige kid clothes jumps 67 in the past
12 months compared with the previous
period all right well let's let's test
your beige meter like how beige is
Harry's room it's like not so I want to
talk about my experience with Beijing
maybe some uh a tick tocker said it
seems to be marketing this fantasy that
if I buy neutrals my children will also
be neutral calm and quiet
but uh pediatric psychologist said it's
important to expose kids to learning
colors and uh to help them with their
visual perception having variety is
important for brain development
so I think this is so interesting
because so many of the like
aesthetic nurseries that I see like
really have so much patience and I
actually buy a decent amount of beige
for Harry I feel like it's my it's the
neutral that I go to in the same way
when I'm looking for myself I would buy
like black or pink like for Harry I'm
like I want beige paper and beige
chandelier yeah uh rocking chair beige
curtains and now I'm like oh my God it's
such a it's a scheme and I'm just like
another Millennial mom who's falling no
you're not because because you're not
letting it like infiltrate Harry spends
like his whole day in that playpen in
the living room
right also the thing is yes I try to
bring more beige into our world but I'm
like an inherently colorful person and
even though I try to I'm trying to
create like a neutral vibe in my house
like everything winds up colorful so his
Nursery is actually not I don't I
actually can't think of a single beige
item that's in there try as I may you
know yeah no like the big main pieces
like the rocking chair the rug the
changing table in the crib are like
white beige like normal but you got a
big blue wallpaper you got toys
everywhere it's beautiful it's beautiful
but now I'm going to be aware of the
fact that I was like subliminally being
a follower of this like sad base each
toys for sad base children no that's
actually so true like now that I think
about it everyone I see on Instagram has
like crazy ass like but you know I went
to Brian's nursery and his is like it's
like lived it's actually now that I
think about it it's a perfect
combination of like being really pretty
and aesthetic but like hella colorful
because it's jungle themed so like
there's lion there's like Safari
wallpaper like animals everywhere a
chalkboard and I did do quite a colorful
um drawing so it actually it's perfect
yeah so I would just say like this this
was a wake-up call for me thankfully I'm
not so I hadn't fallen so deep into the
sad base Trend but I would have
I would have if no one like called out
that I'm just being like marketed to as
a millennial mom who's like just looking
for a calm environment for myself but
that's not like what baby needs no and
what baby needs greater than what you
need yeah especially in their room like
go make your own right beige room right
and your room these days is like
totally with your new wallpaper like you
literally so Harry is literally dying
for some stimulation some colors no he
comes to my room and looks my wallpaper
and he's like oh my gosh I need this so
I I actually am not done with his room
and there will be no more beige
it's there I'm going full primary colors
Kids Fun playroom I think this was the
first time that you told me about an
internet Trend and looking up I was
watching her Instagram sad base children
um but I think she's really big on Tick
Tock and it's [ __ ] fun I will it's
really really funny well I thought those
were some great robust Dynamic stories I
really did I agree which is why my Royal
news might have to wait till tomorrow
let's see what the day holds in store
for us we'll see what tomorrow brings
for our final episode of the week and
then next week we are uh in studio
Monday Tuesday Wednesday and then of
course Thursday Friday and the weekend
we are off for Thanksgiving so please
keep that in mind
um if you haven't gotten your toast
merch there is some Supply left uh some
sizes are sold out but toastmerch.com
any last minute gifts for you for the
toaster in your life for
anyone it's really just it's for all
except for the bigfoots so well the game
slippers are sold out I believe so oh I
guess we had enough small footed
toasters sft
thank you so much for listening to the
toast the millennial Morning Show where
we deliver the past five stories that
you need to know every Monday through
Friday on YouTube so if you're watching
this on YouTube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so at
Spotify iTunes Stitch or public radio
iheartradiocastbox all the places where
we listen to podcasts find us the
toaster leave a five-star review about
how wickedly talented we are hope you
guys have an amazing Thursday and we'll
see you tomorrow for
Friday Friday gotta get down on Friday
goodbye goodbye goodbye